[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hey
welcome back to the break room this new
rockstars daily look at all geek news
coming straight to you on youtube oh
it's this camera don't know which one it
is you told me look it's like red light
and i refuse coming up we're talking
about thor love and thunder episode
three of miss marvel and some deadpool 3
news but you guys it's not about me
today it's about erica
oh my baby yeah i am i came out of you
just like tommy bechtol hey
camera 4 right now
listen to me
your trash bags i am the straw you are
the turtle noses i will jam myself
inside of you if i have to i'm going to
be gone for a week and a half so i need
you to listen up right now reward us
today in the super chat you get stingy i
get out of here okay we got a big crew
you like eric voss guess what he's right
next to me i'll kill eric foster
that's right i've asked him to things
aren't going great with me up here right
now but i'm here
on the break room thanks for inviting me
back everybody of course and as you guys
know and as you you we've done this
while you were here we have redemptions
in the chat every hundred dollars we are
going to redeem the reverse swear jar i
bet you know what a normal swear jar is
sure damn dude
we give you money now
wait wait
so the reverse swear jar is you're not
allowed to curse until we break a
hundred dollars and the way they can
break a hundred dollars is by sending in
super chats which you can just send
questions that we answer at the end of
the show or just want to say hello or if
you want boss to say your name uh it
seems like that's what you guys want
otherwise i won't say your name
he doesn't care about you and neither do
i
he speaks for all of us
oh my god and with that let's get into
the headlines
our number one headline kevin feige said
while shooting thor ragnarok taikawa tt
was reading mighty thor when tyga agreed
to come back he knew he wanted to do
this storyline
it's a very taikawati thing to also be
doing while making a giant movie is to
be reading another comic book just
knocking on the trailer door like taika
we really need you hold on
that was good that was a really good
idea i can't do a full paragraph just a
little burst a little dispersed
i'm just glad to hear one of these like
creators actually did read the comics
this time because they don't always read
them they don't that was uh that was the
case with juan division but i think this
one is also really nice because he was
like when they asked him to do another
movie he knew immediately what he wanted
to work on that is nice yeah and he
picked the best one i mean this is
a great follow-up i'm glad it's also him
doing it i don't know if i want anyone
else to touch this i'm like taika doing
this is going to make it fun but also
you know like with the whole jane foster
storyline i'm like he can he can
approach it very well yeah he corrects
this he's got yeah he's a compassionate
man i trust him
i trust him with my body i trust him
with my eyes
you trust a little too much he's asked
dude i give myself to you tyco
i give my soul to you he sent you cease
and desist to stop trusting him i
thought oh i thought it said seize and
persist
you've used that he's used that before
yeah
please don't oh
no baby i love it five dollars someone
said jess is looking amazing get that
five dollars back she doesn't deserve it
she's too mean she does look amazing we
all know and that's what makes it hurt
oh my god you know what else hurts what
reese uh rhett reese
slam dunk on that segment okay right
here not all of us are good
that's hard
speaking of looking good rhett reese
says deadpool 3 will be a fish out of
water story but isn't it already been
like a fish water storm maybe for the
audience i don't know i feel like he's
brought us into his crazy world this has
got to be like he's in the ensue now
he's the fish out of water the water
being his uh his ocean of weird x-men
continuity and now he's in the mcu where
he's got rules that he's got to follow
you can't upset the mouse now no guns no
killings well we did uh we did a little
bit piece on this before where the
writers were like we're not going to
abide by disney standards we're still
going to make it rated r so it's going
to be a rated r disney movie
finally
exactly all we wanted um i didn't think
about it your way and it's such a boss
way of thinking i truly was like it's
already a fish out of a water story and
it's a certain extent yeah he's always
kind of like the odd one out in every
room that he walks into i just think
like now the world is like he's he has
to react to the world because he's in
like kevin feige's vision
we're getting a lot of uh comments that
my microphone sounds weird
uh i don't know if that's true
do you want to fix it for me did you
blow it out is it upside down
take it
well i think the hair on your chest is
whispering
how about now
pictures
oh people are just uh trash okay well we
knew that already oh god speaking of not
trash you guys uh new thor love and
thunderclip teases the dangers you guys
i'm trying you're doing great so good
the new thor love and thunder clip
teases the dangers of christian bale's
gore and i think we got a little clip
there in the show
you're in the shadow realm how do you
know
the atmosphere there has a darkness like
no other it's as if color feels to tread
it's unmistakable
well then if it's color we need
let's bring the rainbow
bring the rainbow is that catchphrase or
something she's only going to thor for a
minute i mean saving lives she's quite
good at but the rest of it she needs
work how many catchphrases have there
been a lot
yup
jumped the gun
hang on he moves through shadows and
he's going to the shadow realm it seems
like that's where he's going to be the
most powerful you're right we can't just
go marching in there it could be a trap
are you thinking what i think you're
thinking i'm thinking it what are we
thinking thinking we're taking it too
much
i love that i'm gonna love this movie so
much
natalie portman just fitting right into
that comedic timing of like be right
back i'm gonna bring the rain but
whatever she said like that's such she's
playing into the trope and then they're
they're calling her out as they should
okay so we're talking shadow realm right
we're talking around a little bit also
what to what you just said i don't think
i've seen natalie portman play like
comedic have right have we instead of
like there was a lot of blacks one right
super nice she was in a little movie
called no strings attached or just
friends which were two movies that came
out at the exact same time with the
exact same storyline about can two
friends have a intimate relationship and
still remain friends or will eventually
one of them fall in love you can hear
more about that in my
f buddy breakdown coming out friday
where i go into all the easter eggs in
sexy legs
everybody friday my favorite day of the
week that's right p-g-i-f-b-f
that's too much but the shadow what is
this the shadow realm yeah i love in the
same week we learned about the nora
dimension mrs marvel spoilers you
haven't seen ms marvel yet watch that
show i think i'm having so much fun i
love this marvel yes it's very good but
they're kind of playing from the same
playbook it feels like they're
introducing new realms and dimensions so
we understand that there's like the
multiverse we understand there's
different timelines but now we have like
different realms that kind of feel like
it's somewhere in between like
multiverse of madness hinted at what
looked like hell right yeah and i feel
like uh through moon night we're
learning of these spiritual afterlifes i
feel like the shadow realm is some kind
of pocket reality anytime you hear a
realm think of the ancestral plane think
of the astral realm you know the astral
plane uh it feels like
my mind immediately goes to anywhere
there is darkness or a shadow
a gore can pop out of us
through different um using the mirror
dimensions yeah could appear out of any
reflective surface
so i feel like using the same kind of
tactic so they have to provide light
everywhere they can they can't go any
dark alley
they can't go out at nighttime
is a demon he is a boogeyman a spiritual
creature holy i can't curse
this is just my speculation
now department said got to get light
and like dipped out into the ceiling i
think that's insane that oh my god also
this shadow realm it made me think that
this is the finally the mcu yugioh
crossover i've been waiting for all my
uh one of sonic's uh
a bit on wikileaks
[Music]
i'm your dirty little hound job peanut
butter peter shut this side of the table
but
i'll vote in the chat if you want to
cancel eric voss and tell me right now
on that i don't want to read the polls
never tell me the odds
who deserves to get more cancelled oh me
definitely you tommy the now we got a
little insight you guys it's not really
marvel not really dc but a lot of fun
the we call it the break room barbie
watch if you know the acronym you know
the acronym bbw
zombie definitely titled it
we got some uh images from the new
barbie movie by greta gerwig
look at how fine that suit is oh my god
that's a pretty scary in that barbie fit
we could have been barbie again we could
you guys are the break room barbie in
ken for sure and by the way there's some
fringe on those outfits but this movie
is main stream
[Laughter]
and the moment has passed i think the i
think this movie's going to
crush it i'm so excited it's going to be
awesome
we want we want tickets to the premiere
the break room wants to be at the
premiere for this movie we want a
private screening with all of our best
barbie and ken friends we want to have
we want to be hosting things for you
guys reach out to us i don't even know
who's making the barbie movie is it
someone like greta gerwig no i know but
what production company
i assume
who's mattel in bed with is it lion's
date is it yeah ryan someone reach out
call in if you know the answer uh also
take me to camera too really quick
warner brothers brothers my old friends
at warner brothers oh yeah we're right
down the street get me on camera too
john um greta if you're out there you
came into barnes and noble about four
years ago when i was working looking for
your magazine with you on the cover i
know you remember me i'm the only black
girl working there um i'm sure you
remember that ever yeah probably you're
working on that um please give me
tickets to the premiere please give me
tickets to the premiere i promise i will
talk only good about this i don't know
what it looks like but i'm going to i
need to i love barbie and give me camera
four real quick ryan you once saw me do
a two-person improv show at the improv
olympic on hollywood boulevard talking
to gosling now uh you were one of three
people in the audience
we didn't do great but afterwards you
came up and you slapped me way too hard
on the shoulder and said hey great job
man and i never saw you again and ryan
as the other person in that two-person
improv show i disagree with tommy's
assessment that we didn't do great
because you don't need laughs to know if
you're funny you can't
that's true sometimes tears are just as
validating boss we broke the hundred and
the chat votes you get to swear
do you want to read this next headline
and cuss as much as you want oh sure i
do uh we got some great details from
multiverse of madness commentary
including richie palmer saying [ __ ] all
you
[ __ ] we're just reshooting this
movie and putting it together finding it
in post [ __ ] you no he didn't say that
he said that they actually used a scan
of elizabeth olsen's eye to create
gargantuas's eyeball as a way to
foreshadow the film's real villain i
think that's amazing by the way i mean i
knew there was some characterization
going on in that eye i'm like those
animators did great work no no no they
didn't do [ __ ] it was elizabeth olsen
doing all the activities
also that's the little that's the little
things that i like in those films the
little things it's like yeah she made
these monsters let them have a little
piece of her let them have a little
piece and i'm told that eyeball was
practical right yeah
fully functioning all right so we should
say we're we're at 140 now if we get to
200 we gotta do something special we
gotta spice it up a little bit can't
just be another vote on the sweat what
do you think a little bit of spice
we'll just do spicy how about uh if we
get to 200
should we
should we roast whoever gets us over 200
should we
yeah we each can roast them yeah okay
here's what no here's what we're gonna
do if we get over 200 we're gonna we're
going to uh give another random fact
that's a lie about doctor strange with
profanity
from behind the scenes everybody
everybody will give another fact about
the movie maybe it's true maybe it's
something we're not allowed to share
that we'll we'll do through this silly
device yeah the next headline sam raimi
um said the defender strange is actually
from earth 617 yes okay great do we
one hundred percent one hundred percent
that we know well i think the that does
kind of shut down the really fun theory
that was out there that defender strange
could have come from the rainy verse
yeah i like that idea a lot because we
know there's a doctor stranger can we
just act like 617 is the rainbow verse i
think it has its own numerical
designation but that numerical
designation was in the same system that
said that mcu is earth 19999 and now
that earth is mcu-616
i don't know if that number applies
anymore true so we don't know well i
think it i think the fans decide no yeah
i think iman valani decides
has final say i'm fine with that now we
do need to thank uh desiree cowling who
got us over the first mark with a 50
uh super chat i love all the content you
produced desiree we appreciate that very
much thank you desiree and uh yeah and
we want to thank uh who else we got we
got zeus 13
says uh oh it's moving around i love you
jess but i will not cancel eric who else
will panic about cameron and kamala
being cousin
he's totally panicked right now he was
right to panic
we'll talk about we'll we'll get into it
i still have a problem with the actual
love interest okay because technically
still cousins
get into it
okay we'll talk about that yeah oh oh
thank you john uh they established that
the rainy versus earth one nine two four
two three or something like that yeah
it's it's it's it's it's out there it's
okay perfect do we wanna do oh wait did
we go over for the super chats we have
not gone over yet we're at 190 right now
we need 10 more dollars and then i the
chat wants to roast more than they want
my dumb behind-the-scenes thing so we're
going to roast away we'll roast away
both
yeah
why not why not sam raimi confirms the
lead scene from wakan uh from wakanda
sorry guys sam raimi confirms deleted
scene of wanda killing 616 mordo and
multiverse madness she killed him and
cuts his head off presented it to
strange in a later scene wow that put
these scenes in the movie you know they
couldn't sam raymond absolutely wanted
it but if they tell you he's like no jim
halpert's head yeah if they could
implode but it was so cartoony the way
the illuminati died that i think they
got away with the only one that wasn't
cartoony was um was uh
oh no that one was what spurred it out
of his nose
his eyes go boom and then he i guess it
was a bit cartoon
it was also very sam raimi those deaths
it was evil dead so much this though how
is that evil dead i mean did you watch
drag me to hell at one point there a
body gets possessed by a demon and then
he starts doing a little puppet dancing
that's kind of fun
and it's super funny a goat starts
singing yeah
yeah really funny all right i think they
could have pulled it off i mean we know
there's a scene from endgame they
drafted out a scene where thanos is
going to roll captain america's head at
the feet of the avengers
it would have been crazy you're right it
might have been a little too dark but i
mean people watch this movie and we're
like it's
dark i think it was a good intro to
scary for like a 12 year old or a 10
year old that was like i want skewey
it's like this is pretty good i think it
was very scary i think what's even
scarier is that engage
gave us twenty dollars says roast me
please
what's your biggest name that's easier
to say
choose someone that's super chatty go
ahead and give them a little roast yeah
you go ah let's see
mr krabs right okay mr krabs uh what do
you got crabs actually huh go [ __ ]
yourself
ah yeah yeah take that for giving us
money
yeah who else wow we're almost to 300
that means we're gonna be nice
it flips back so i don't want to roast
you because you know i watched the
umbrella academy within the ten hours it
came out so i will roast you umbrella
academy oh
i hope that umbrella gets struck by
lightning because your show sucks yeah
what are you covering all your goddamn
dandruff from coming off your head you
you dirty head fool like whoa
uh a
baby back [ __ ] face that's what you
want yeah
yeah
yeah who else who else wants some
mochikatsu five dollars take that five
dollars and shove it up your ass
and then if we reach 300 we'll be nice
to one of you yeah we're close today
yeah we're at 300 now so adam kajawa
god you're a sweetheart adam we thank
you so much for watching the show we
really appreciate that your [ __ ] ass
comes on over and watching the show
every day thank you so much
um
mochi katsu love mochi love you thanks
wow
say something nice i i can't it's not in
my hardware um
adam
oh
walmart price it's a good price it's an
agreeable price and i love that it's not
10 which would have broken my piggy bank
that's especially for that goddamn
cheapskate
we got one more headline one more
headline and then we'll get into our our
meaty discussions you guys the
multiverse of madness sculptor has
revealed the best look yet at the wiccan
statue from mount wondergore do we have
a picture of it
john behind the scene said
[Music]
it looks like julian hilliard and he's
got like a sash and he looks he looks
dynamite to be honest um no yeah i think
uh i i now i'm so glad this movie is out
and like high def so i can actually see
these things uh so we'll be doing a
re-breakdown of all the easter eggs oh
beautiful yeah no more we're not going
to talk about it anymore because we're
talking talk away we're saving
sorry i didn't want you to have to work
it if you if you had more to read uh so
now listen to me if we get to 400 we got
to do something special we don't get to
400 a lot on this show what can we do
what's the redemption for 400 dollars
what's something that we've been
deep in our hearts hoping to do to these
trash bags for a long time i can think
of a couple things but they're not legal
in the states okay all right um
look here
can i can i talk about what hell i'd
banish them to yes
yes for 400
we will banish people in the chat to
hell and we will tell them their
specific punishments in this hell led by
our own eric voss king of hell himself
the prince of darkness the king we know
who the king is we know who the king is
this is an m for mephisto
hell mephisto which is just two bees
upside down for boss okay
okay go on i'm sorry i didn't mean that
or
wanda
or tamda
all right well we're not going to talk
about this first part because we already
talked about the headlines communication
so now we're going to talk about the
second we got another trailer that came
out you keep scrolling down we already
covered all of this we we went deep so
uh oh we get well the one thing we did
missing that earlier they talk about an
omnipotence city does anyone know about
an ipad city from the comic books i did
a little research i couldn't really find
much is it are we talking about just
like mount olympus yeah i think that's
what they're referring it's like i think
that might be their name for it it's
meaning like all powerful yeah
all-knowing this perhaps could be where
zeus has gathered everyone for his
little
play around yeah i i think it's
interesting that they call it that like
this all-powerful city it's so like smug
i don't know if that's their name for it
or literally zeus is like welcome
yes
this is kind of one of your it's such
like a rick and morty world building
concept i really love that there is a
lot of rick and morty things from from
this
what we've seen of thor love and thunder
so far the screaming goats and what
we're about to talk about next uh yeah
as well so yeah we also got another
teaser trailer and it gives us a lot
more of the guardians of the galaxy and
even a peek at some celestials now my
question for you guys is how much do you
think the guardians are going to be in
this movie they they mentioned or at
least we talked about it briefly that it
was going to be more than what we
expected and i personally didn't want
that i wanted just like a little bit and
then we go to the store yeah but that's
me yeah a splash of tracks yes what i
want is like a first act yeah
heavy-handed appearance and then i want
them to come back at the end yes yeah
sure i don't i don't need them to be in
the hole i think it's too distracting i
think i agree with you i and i also
think they're giving us a bit of a like
trailer misdirect where he keeps
mentioning the guardians in the trailer
so we're going to think like oh these
guys are all going to be i mean i could
be wrong maybe they're along for the
whole ride but uh yeah false flag red
herring type that's right yes
yeah it's like the the gardener and like
the mad celestial oh because one has
almost like looks like a
like a starfish kind of pattern of this
light so the other have like six
rectangular um uh card slots for eyes
that's interesting that they would even
give zeus the time of day does that make
sense or maybe it tells you something
about the celestials that they're
mid right no no
it seems like everyone who is at any
point described as a god or a higher
power of existence is now being given a
place in the hierarchy in that scene
like that's just for me as someone who's
obsessed with like the mcu world
building and the interconnectivity and
the continuity of it just giving us a
sense of that hierarchy of who sits
above whom and that in that pantheon
it's like yes please can we give
everyone like a numerical designation as
well can we give everyone like a power
status i agree a ranking a ranking oh
that'd be nice like the wrong thing i
haven't done that yet and like on the
marvel website because they give you the
list of like here's their powers and
here's how strong they are here's their
like stats but then it's like are they
number one are they number two are they
an omega yeah oh we should do like a
weekly like sports center show about
like power rankings for whoa
like there's a new king in town after
thor love and thunder korg is now the
most powerful character in the galaxy
you're a sports person you're also a
sports person sure did you technically
before a movie comes out like before we
go see uh the thor 11 thunder make a
bracket of how far you think
like a death bracket yeah oh it'd have
to be like a death i think suicide squad
we definitely could have done that and
if they make a thunderbolts or a suicide
squad sequel we should do that okay
let's do it yeah i think we should do
that as a mini series hey how about we
throw this up as a poll would you rather
see a ranking mini series that ranks
like that counts down to number one or
would you rather see a bracket
miniseries that pitch people against
each other
just a little programming uh
surveying you you know what we're doing
a little focus group you're the viewers
we care about you're the viewers who
make time in your day to come visit us
hang out with us you're the ones we open
up the lids of our dumpsters peer in and
say thanks for watching
youtube settle
both of you
the bad boys the bad boys of the office
can't take y'all nowhere
literally
i also think something about being on
this side of the table just turns you
into a little a little bad boy because
when i'm on that side
excuse me they call me little jinx i
just poop my pants until the government
invests me oh boy go speaker
government intervention i want to thank
manscaped uh there's a certain
confidence that comes with being
properly groomed there's an aura a vibe
you can tell just by the way people
carry themselves we call this bge big
groomed energy and there's only one way
to get that bge that's manscape baby
we'd like to introduce you to the best
and biggest ultimate hygiene bundle yet
the platinum package 4.0
manscaped is the leader in below the
waist grooming you want those hardwood
floors you got to get a manscape now
trust them with the rest just
just join the four million men worldwide
who trust manscaped by going to
manscape.com for 20 off plus free
shipping with the code break room now
when i was a boy
i had this eccentric neighbor she was
this rich old lady with black and white
hair every time i'd see her in the
street she'd look at me with these
greedy eyes
later one day i heard my dad negotiating
a deal with her to make a code out of me
anyway thanks to manscape she no longer
even acknowledges that i'm alive i miss
you mrs c
or mrs d mrs cruella d
package 4.0 is the biggest bundle
they've ever offered giving you the bulk
discount on manscape top product
products the manscape pack platinum
package 4.0 is the one stop shop for the
man who deserves it all and that's you
they designed this package to allow you
to fully align your entire hygiene
routine with the with elite products
inside this platinum package you'll find
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer and god you
know i need it i can barely hear anymore
there's so many hairs growing in my ears
the ultra premium body wash the ultra
premium two in one shampoo plus
conditioner no need to buy two separate
that's for lazy people ultra premium
deodorant crop preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant my personal favorite crop
reviver ball spray toner we're losing
the balls we're losing the balls clear
mrs testicles we saved your husband
don't you call me that your husband
your husband has been revived
plus the anti-chafing boxers and the
shed travel bag to hold all these
goodies while you're traveling get 20
off and free shipping with the code
break room at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com use
code breakroom unlock your big groomed
energy with manscape and remember when
you trim the hedges that pull
stands tall oh my god and also some
really fun news get me on camera too i
don't want tommy to talk anymore about
the fans new rockstars is going to be
appearing live in austin texas as part
of the rtx the rooster teeth uh
convention uh austin 22 podcast festival
july 1st through july 3rd and if you
ever wanted to meet literally three of
the four people oh yeah going
performing for you and you get to join
us and hang out with us and play with us
you're gonna this is the opportunity of
a lifetime we did it in chicago and it
was a blast so much fun it was so much
fun and everyone said we were the
funniest people they've ever met their
entire life
um and if and all you have to do is buy
your ticket online and you can save on
your ticket if you use the description
and use the promo code new rockstars and
i think if you do that we just give you
a shout out we yell to you in the
audience we scream hello and you get a
discount you get a discount on your
discount yeah it's going to be a fun
time july 1st through the 3rd in austin
texas make sure you have time and also
wear sunscreen it's texas yeah how's
that come see us because the stars at
night are very
bright
deep in the heart of texas
okay i don't want to be that person but
come on you got i don't know that one
we're texas you've got to keep up with
tech i just went for the first time last
year oh
speaking of first times eric this is
your first time for mandatory fun yeah
that's right the segment's so nice we
play the graphic twice
hit my graphic
yes
it's mandatory fun the segment
so wonderful that we have to play it
three times full hit the graphic again
are there any easter eggs in those um
there might
your life well let's go right now
eric boss okay he's gonna do a deep dive
in the mandatory fun graphic when we hit
it for a fourth
the time never
right now the little fun fact though is
that me i think me tommy and brandon
helped john come up with some phrases
for the graphic like mandatory stuff
now
uh
i know you all think i'm gonna say hit
the graphic again but i'm not i'm gonna
say hit the graphic of barbie and ken
all right now
yesterday's news that dr strange was uh
originally included a draft for the wasp
was part of the illuminati and wando was
set to
smash her out of existence it got me
thinking about other marvel characters
that could have joined the illuminati
only to be killed by wanda now
unfortunately i cannot be here today for
me please don't do this no please don't
so sorry my doctor just called no my
doctor just called me
and it turns out that they have a couple
of uh hippopotamus elbow joints that i
can have i'm having a transplant i'm
slowly having my body replaced by animal
joints and tendons
it's been
pretty miraculous i can't be here now we
did cross the 400
mark so maybe well i'm getting i did
find someone who could take over for
this segment well i find him maybe you
guys could send some people to hell okay
okay well you send megan
megan living
megan living good uh thanks to y'all
from north carolina where you helped me
go in these past years well we're happy
to have helped you but in these next
couple years megan you are going
straight to hell and you know where hell
is it's in durham north carolina
[Applause]
the staircase so may that owl attack you
up and down that staircase forever and
ever in hell uh let's see weigenbach uh
voss say my son
ronan's name he's seven and a huge fan
of yours well ronan thank you so much
for uh for supporting us into wegenbach
but you know what i'm sending you
straight to hell and uh i'm gonna make
you have to um hang out with a version
of ronan who's not actually ronin he's a
he's a little demon who looks like ronan
who's just gonna scream the moment you
try to hug him no that's your hell
that's not weirdly dark and personal
yeah i'm sorry
that's the segment that you asked for it
uh who else you got chrissy christie
says uh tons grenier and tanzanios are
the goats who pulled yeah we know that
we know that
we're going to hell you're going to hell
oh my god i'm just gonna keep uh
shouting people out i think we're in
hell right now hey girl uh mc musical
would each of you want to star in
obviously i can do this all day
and i just sent you the hell with
singing when my voice cracked that's
your hell yeah
me singing in your ear whenever you try
to sleep so go to hell go to healthray
girl and uh desiree you're uh true
improv king your hell is you just have
to sit through uh del close theater uh
improv shows that's the back theater
where the house games they're really
just the the two-tier people who didn't
make the main stage you just got to sit
through and watch shows forever and ever
that's your that's your circle of hell
you're welcome silence
yes it is i
t e michael beck told hollywood
executive
owner and operator and ceo of t michael
bechtold films a subsidiary of skank
productions
winner of three what awards
films that made people go
now
i've been told
there's an illuminati
pitch meeting happening and it just so
happens that d michael bechtel
productions is in search of another what
award
so i ask you
my three best friends
here for mandatory fun by the way this
is my bird perseus okay it's a good name
looks a lot like the bird that we had on
set for westeros weekly in 2017 but
this is perseus and that's all he's ever
been perseus and i are going to hear
your
pictures now pictures from my [ __ ]
that was a show me and tandy newton used
to host
back in 1994 for the bbc
and that doesn't stand for what you
think it does
british broadcasting company yes yes
just like bbw i think it stood for my
god the mind's on some of you i love it
now i'm going to give you a beloved
marvel character and you're going to
tell me each one of you how m wanda
maximoff would have stuffed that
character out good word
first up scott summers aka cyclops
what's that boy
i can't repeat what he said it's too
profane
we'd have to get to 500 for me to reveal
what perseus just said to me i want to
hear what that bird has to say get us
there
get there right now
i don't want to know what that is i
think
uh she would have gotten she would have
duplicated his optic blast lenses and uh
done that wanted move and created a ring
of them to redirect the optic class oh
that's a good one
my god eric voss you're a sick genius i
think um
she would have
taken her dark little crusty black
fingertips and immediately been like oh
okay
just jump through the glasses
and poke a hole like directly in and see
three stooges here and that doesn't
technically kill you that quick it'll
just make you oh my god and so his
powers would be powerful
well technically his eyes are portals
that allow lasers from another land to
shoot out of here there's another
dimension here they're connected
i know perseus i know
i can't believe you didn't know that
don't upset him
i know you two have a checkered pass
i think that juan maximoff would have to
kill cyclops in the illuminati meeting
instead of making the lasers come out of
or through through his eyes they would
have come out his butt and then rotated
around to cut him kind of like this
yes spatchcock the cyclops uh yep awusu
you are my winner yeah
for this round but mandatory fun has 37
rounds before we finish
fear not what's that boy
three rounds
point seven we might ask a bonus chrissy
in the chat said someone should tell uh
t michael beck told that that's a raven
not a crow
i never said it was a crow didn't oh you
didn't say it was a girl what is he
he said westeros i'll be honest i
thought it was a hawk for the place
i thought it was a bald eagle so i for a
while i thought it was a house cat and i
was feeding him
kitty later
i was force feeding him kitty litter oh
[Laughter]
of course joining the illuminati in
draft one of the multiverse of madness
was
x-men
original film villain toad
how would you have killed toad
in a very large slowly boiling pot of
water oh
and he doesn't even realize he doesn't
realize how gradually hot it's getting
oh
that's so tragic i get some good toad
legs out of that i think she would uh
put fire works up his butt fire works up
a frog's butt i should my brother
raymond died in a hot tub that way
he was in a fireworks first
fireworks jammed up his ass
that's what was bubbling the water he
actually paid someone to do it that was
the worst easter egg
we didn't we cancelled the egg hunt
after that but still he has risen but he
did rise three days later to the top of
the tub so we could bury him it was a
deep club
geneva new york deepest tubs in the
world deepest lake in the world
a lot of bodies and secrets in lake
geneva eric yes i think uh wanda maximov
would have killed toad uh by hitting him
in the head with a blue shell from mario
kart that's the toad i'm thinking so
just boom just smash yep
you're all wrong unfortunately she would
have created a little fly
that was made of poison and then he
would have gone
and he would have swallowed the fly and
the fly would have killed him slowly
painfully over a course of years his
wife painstakingly nursing him at his
bedside mrs toad why can't we get my
husband right the doctors can't find
anything wrong the scans are all coming
clear
but the poison
the poison takes him next i can't
believe we didn't know that yeah
i feel like that was a gimme layup
answer the member of the illuminati who
you will kill next is hulk
hmm
how would you i would want to kill hulk
good hulk death oh yeah you didn't think
these were going to be thinkers did you
because they're all going to be layups
well i don't like to make my friends
look good
i like to make my friends look nasty
don't look at me
well we saw the hulk death and what if
right he just inflated until he popped
that's a pretty epic kill in and of
itself well uh i think hulk dies just
like at the end of watching all of his
other friends die at the end of the
world and he's the last one alive and he
has to bury all of his friends and he
kills himself
oh that's a good one damn i think um
like
you know how like when he was destroying
new york he was like flipping taxis and
everything i want all the things that
he's destroyed to fall on top of him so
i want her to just make like a portal of
all the crushed things that he crushed
in the first movie and just murder him
that way it was harlem so i would love
to see the apollo theater fall out of
the sky and just impale just the sandman
sad hook rise from the rubble
taking one last soul to hell that's what
happens when the sandman takes you away
right yeah you just go i performed at
the apollo in 1977. new york times said
never again
please i don't want it
brantley is brutal how to kill the whole
okay so i think wanda
would do her
og powers like make him see things and
make him see thunderbolt ross
and when he goes to clap and kill
thunderball ross it's actually his own
head so he explodes his own head and
kills himself
because he's the only person in the mind
like you know
he claps his own cheeks these cheeks
you've done it again we ought to get you
over to
skank films in an internship unpaid you
got an opening we do yeah i have an
opening for skank films
uh well most of us have several openings
last but not least night crawler speed
round
oh
that's oh that's another character
i thought you said three uh yes i lie i
said 3.7 night crawler speed round 0.7 i
love to lie i know you do that's on my
letterhead team michael bechtold ceo
team michael beckfeld films i love to
lie i love to lie
um
oh you said nightcrawler yes um
kurt walkner um
oh god i'm trying to go i think uh she
has some teleport uh she like redirects
his teleportation so it's inside one of
those uh it's at the edge of an
escalator
right as it's going back into the gears
and recycling to the start and so he
gets sucked down to the escalator and
his body gets ground to bits
i want him to jump teleport around and
then i i want her to kill the rest of
them first and then for him just like
pull out a knife and stab it oh the
jones like
big bad fight and then just pull out the
pistol and shoot the sword juggler yes
very good jessica very good i want her
oh he is not a fan of yours three
dollars to figure out the beast between
me and this freaking bird
we're already way over it we're at 500
now
sorry eric what were you going to say oh
good i want wanted to redirect uh
nightcrawler's teleport so he lands
right in front of the car being driven
by jake gyllenhall in nightcrawler and
that is what kills my crawler
[Music]
that's graphic i'm going to have to go
with jessica
jessica i like your pitch
now to reveal what
said uh eric voss perseus was whispering
in my ear you know yesterday when he was
baby birding you those worms
those weren't worms those were his dicks
he's multiple dicks
oh
i'm off to the premiere of fork
it's a parody film of thor about a
viking fork
jesus let's go over some of the polls
while this monster slowly leaves is that
hay in his
show
has deadpool always been a fish out of
water story 66 of you said yes it has
always been so we kind of agree uh would
you prefer would you prefer a bracket
style or ranking mini series they say
bracket style yeah 57 yeah
good to know who had the best cyclops
kill eric voss
me whatever
um who had the best toad kill sure
don't ever allow him back yeah well
i don't know who's on the list he didn't
do good yeah we gotta put his face up by
the door so we don't let him in
unfortunately i did not get those
rhinoceros or hippopotamus elbow joints
they were fresh out so i
got lemur joints nice time oh my god oh
my god one with the best hulk kill two
oh thank you thank you thank you the
winners today are eric i wish my name is
on his way out he did say something
about
your nightcrawler kill he really enjoyed
it tell him i don't enjoy him no you
don't like perseus hey we broke five
hundred on the reverse swear to god
five hondo it came so quick okay
well we'll send some more people to hell
how about that yeah go ahead we already
answered mo and uh we already answered
you so
jt
tys
yeah uh jt
uh
how about just the
go in hell that's a jp
uh
your your hell is going to have to be um
uh so you and justin timberlake for jt
both get involved in scandals but for
whatever reason the media blames you for
it
so that's your hell jt
uh mountain ways 46 uh your hell is that
uh
you are married to someone who insists
on navigating through a mountain pass
but will not listen to you when you try
to direct them so that's your health
forever and ever
uh aj stanton i assume andrew stanton uh
your hell is that um uh people know that
you behind the scenes at pixar are
actually kind of mean to your assistants
i'm saying that we'll move on give me
another one i've got to tell someone who
else who we need we have mountain waves
no we already did mountain way m.o
you're in line at marshall's behind an a
small european woman and she's got twice
as many things than what that she's
going to actually buy but she won't make
those decisions until she gets to the
register and then she puts half of the
things back and then she signs up for a
credit card and then she can't activate
the credit card this is just what
happened to me at marshall's yesterday
it felt like okay it felt like him right
now
vargas said send me anywhere you want
jess baby i'm gonna send you to my house
which i hate but you probably will enjoy
it silk walls i hate silk uh the fridge
is full of mayonnaise hate mayonnaise
and all that's playing on tv is
damn
new rock stars oh it's eric boss's
breakdown
so you will love this hell i will wait a
second silk walls i hate silver
silk
i can see you in like the flyest silk
robes ever i can't i can't like i don't
like the feeling but how do you feel
about burlap okay so anyway
is that a hard note
we have our second discussion and we'll
we're gonna try to make this
quick and brief because we only have a
couple more minutes okay episode three
of ms marvel dropped on wednesday and we
got some big details about how uh where
the show is heading right off the bat um
if i can figure out how this mouse works
i can tell you how to get over that tv
which one oh over here there you go
uh want me to do it oh yes please so
first question oh yeah first question
hot question where in the hell is that
second bangle at i think somewhere in
the uk right that's what they said in
the show but do you think it was
confiscated maybe brought somewhere else
yeah i think it's either in dodc storage
because we know they just have all kinds
they've got ultron heads in there
they've got shitaray tech it wouldn't
surprise me if they also have some
pre-tech does the kiritek only work well
does the bagel officially only work if
it's on someone that has that blood in
them you think because do you think it
wouldn't have turned on when the dodc
had it
that's a great question i mean you would
think that someone would have been able
to use it before otherwise well you have
to is it one of those things where like
you have to be worthy for it to activate
i don't or a certain bloodline i think
it was more of the bloodline because
they were like you have the power deep
inside you the bengals just helping you
uh
supporting you with it so i think it has
to be the blood
but they got me in the blood we're just
bloody and blood out yeah
they're just a bunch of liars we don't
know yeah
i'm not dressing the
what do you think they're hiding what do
we think the clandestines are hiding oh
i mean i obviously we know they don't
care about uh wrecking this dimension
yeah there's a planet yeah to get home
though yeah i think they were banished i
think they did something naughty yeah
that makes sense but they
that would imply though then that uh
that uh kamala's uh grandmother was her
great-grandmother was complicit in doing
something nice yeah a lot of our great
grandparents were complicit not mine
they were angels
mine are and still will be angels um i
well
sorry too much i keep calling it
bluetooth too much um g-fuel yeah oh
what do we think that i it's like yeah
they did something bad but i also don't
think they're clandest does that make
sense i don't think that they're what
they say they are i think over like lore
and storytelling they're like this is
just what people call this but we are
actually just scrolls or something like
i just i think that they're just
something else that well do we think
that maybe that like they like that uh
they have somehow the intuition that
they know that uh kamala is afraid of uh
jinns so that's why she said that they
call us jin you know yeah just knowing
that that would be a specific fear or at
least put it on her heels maybe yeah
maybe this direction maybe uh yeah i i
think they are from another dimension
like what i mean hey this would be the
first time the mcu someone lied about
being from another dimension right i
would just since we saw mysterio do it i
think it'd be weird if these guys did
especially since we do see it it does
open a portal we saw
kamala go back into what looked like
some other realm so i think we can trust
that they are from another dimension i
think clandestine how important that
will be to their identity i don't know i
don't think it really matters
that much
i agree they did have powers like when
they pulled out their weapons the dude
brought out his
extra long belt i loved it
i loved it yeah it was kind of hot yeah
they can kind of turn their their
fashion apparel into weapons or they're
really good with it well that's why i
was thinking that that um like because
the guy's like zipper or something
turned he was wearing a necklace he had
a pendant and he like tapped it and then
it turned into a video that's the
technology that's the creed tech i don't
think that's like them being gods or
anything i think that's just the tech
that they have that they came with they
can they can turn
zippers the web
stupid technology
you think it is until you're making a
fire energy blast out of out of
bengals if you've ever closed your
zipper too fast when you shouldn't you
know a zipper can be a weapon any old oh
true weapon against yourself so do we
i've seen there's something that's rare
did you just rest
karachi
what is the connection to the bangle um
of the what is the connection of the arm
the bangle was on being blue do we
actually think
that i thought they were scrolls i was
like this is a screen i think they're
creative i think scrolls are green i
don't know there might be different
shades of green
no i think it's cree at the end of the
day
i think what i think this is just my
theory based off of episode two i think
that was the site where when we found
the ten rings oh wow instead of being
mcluhan tech i think they're just gonna
say the ten rings were creetech
it simplify it a little bit and then uh
so when we discovered this sometime like
over a thousand years ago use these ten
rings to beat up whatever cree were
there he got in a fight with the cree
severed their arm left it there and then
now he has some kind of weird respect
for these uh interdimensional beings
maybe they're from tallow or from beyond
where the dweller in darkness was and he
said hey we'll make a deal you get the
bangle i'll keep the rings
i like that i agree with that i want to
try doing sorry guys though we had to
speed through this i just want to make
sure we get your questions answered
because we don't have owusu and vos here
every day so let's try getting these uh
yasi yasi yasi well it says well we see
a cameo maybe from captain marvel and
miss marvel i think so i think so yeah
that'd be really cool like my final
episode it would be awesome it'd be
awesome if not if they did like at the
end of shazam when superman just from
the neck down it's just like it's just
like half of her suit flies into frame
great job kid and then
yes
flies
p says does ms marvel's mom have the
ability to use the bengals too
i think so i think they all do i
established the of the bloodline yeah i
think they all do and i think the
brother is going to be the first one to
use it that's not her um i think she's
going to get in trouble the band is
going to fall off and her brother's
gonna find it and use it for a second or
he'll either the brother or the mom will
find the other bengal and it'll be a
family team
yes i will love that uh trisha says and
rockstars are they mega bands
mega bands or the or they're calling
mega bands or the nega bands because
that's the cree tech
or maybe you know something else called
mega pants
i don't know if they will call it that
um just because it's supposed the reason
they're called as they're linked to the
negative zone
uh so unless like the msu is ready to
establish the negative zone i think
that's something they'll say for
fantastic four but uh who knows like
maybe they'll say the nord dimension is
the negative zone i just think i don't i
don't think they're gonna pull the
trigger on that yet yeah i'm perfect we
have another and i'm sorry for for a
dosha
for some persona i'm so sorry you guys
you know i'm not the one that's good
with names i'm sorry for butchering do
you believe when wu was a part of the
gin uh getting exiled that'd be so sick
that'd be so sick i don't think so but
that would be so sick
like they made some deal with him or
something like that and that was a
betrayal to their own dimension i think
their story is separate from him because
uh he didn't know that there was a
dweller in darkness on the other side of
the gate in tomorrow he just thought it
was his wife over there so i don't think
he would know that much about it so that
he could like have been helpful in
getting them exiled anyway um okay and
last one for shod said what's the deal
with sana's seeing the karachi train to
oh the truck oh the train and the light
oh and the grandma being able to see it
i i don't know yeah i don't think i
haven't seen i haven't seen any part of
that yet in the comics so i truly do not
know yeah we're really unsure of
territory i mean if if santa saw it
presumably munita saw it too right the
mom oh yeah oh 100. all the women were
still alive this family had a vision of
a train a karachi train i honestly think
what it means is like these these gin
these clandestine pushed aisha in front
of a train and she wouldn't tell them
where she hid the bank
so i think that's what that means like
anytime you see a train crashing at you
i think it's like oh it's like inception
i mean
that's just i don't know you guys thank
you for joining us today thank you thank
you
thank you
thank you tommy thank you eric boss
thanks for allowing me to come back for
a day yeah someone in the chat said uh
we just need to get him out of that blue
dungeon for at least a day and honestly
that's all i need this is the little
break that you need yeah the light's
returning to his eyes
between his eyes make sure um to keep up
with all the breakdowns that are coming
out uh
we're seeing thor love and thunder
tonight a lot of stuff is gonna be
happening
can't wait tell me about it i'm gonna
i'm gonna uh tell you guys everything
you know i'm gonna out the entire story
line uh we have the boys underground on
friday being released we're gonna talk
about hear orgasm you guys have been
saying in the chat i see it we're gonna
get into it uh make sure to like
subscribe follow share the share the
channel share the wealth with everybody
and join us again tomorrow in the
afternoon at 3 p.m even
even have a nice night
later gators
let us get us
[Music]